my name is Cara I was a teenager when I
started modeling but this is the first
time I've spoken about my sex life
so let's talk about it
I'm going to travel the world
to discover what makes each of us who we
are I love men but oh I love women and
everyone else
so
you come here often
I'm going to meet people like me and
others very unlike me all of us are
trying to figure out who we are I don't
know who I am like a lot of people don't
know who they are
I'm pretty nervous to put my sexual
desires out there at a women-only sex
party I am married but there's a part of
me that needs more I'm going on a
journey to discover what else there is
ladies gentlemen and those of us smart
enough to have transcended gender
[Applause]
Warren intersex is it something you're
quite scared of it's like a relief
because it was just like oh my God
Community peoples and then at the same
time it was like what the [ __ ]
when I was a little girl I liked
dressing up in boys clothes whoa this is
crazy I'm in the body of a man I'm so
good what my family I've been thinking
there's nothing against them they love
me it's just some people don't
understand what that is we are on the
right path
is made from this very male Viewpoint so
I'm pitching my ideas to Erica lust I
want to change porn culture she's going
to direct the porn film based on my
fantasies
we deserve orgasms
am I brave enough to change the
narrative and shed the shame the bravest
thing I've ever done can't believe I did
it to be honest
growing up with a lot of Shame thinking
this isn't normal this isn't human but
it's like it is
there's so much more to explore